je suis à la plage je l'attends c'est
nous avec mon maillot
soit la plage entourée
non mais c'est vrai je vois charmant des
mecs comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
voilà oui alors oui ça vous avez
tellement par différemment après cette
année notamment vous vois déjà dû faire
nord une jeune fille vient une géo pas
une jeune fille bien sûr la page et me
dit matthieu delormeau oui parce que la
connaissez ballottés les bons choix
n'est pas débile me aka la wii balla
gaye tv5monde ya plein de choses des
médias qui m'ont va pas surpris je
suis connu comme un petit peu ma au club
med et français laver ou c'est pas la
ligue 2
[Applaudissements]
je suis en droit de poser des questions
alors oui c'est ce couple à la réception
et un coup de téléphone pour vous non
quelqu'un qui n'a pas menti portable
visiblement beaucoup de bien parce que
juré c'est vrai je prends le téléphone
allô attend - your ass et l ozone
[Rires]
c'est matthew
[Applaudissements]
taylor
hélas
[Applaudissements]
cette guerre
nous jetaient mini
est donc alors prononcé goût bon ils
vont relancer mon nom
bonjour brioches maillot bonjour rafael
nadal
on n'est pas loin et on entend les bien
quelque chose je jugeais 20 témoins
chevaux lourds donc le mac do you we
moyens ils avaient ils avaient de
patates dans la bouche c'est julio
iglesias
alors on est des bilans mais plutôt un
public jeune
shérif parce qu'il a des tas coach et
j'avais fait ma première à droite s'est
elle habitait alors à briquet henrique
guerra laquelle j'aurais aimé oui non
parce qu'ils apprennent de castaldi
après quand je sais c'est qu'on le
design riz qu il ait jamais non un
mélange tonique aux salaires et la fobio
méfier des cours
[Applaudissements]
cette série que les médias
le magazine you tube
ça fait preuve de grande générosité
alors c'est vrai
tu étais mathieu tout et mathieu oui
tous mes matches du oui matthieu
delormeau mais c'est le club med qui
paye blague oui mais l'animateur
l'animateur qui m'a très choqué
mais qu'on n'est pas bien de carrière
qui avait démarré bénard je te
connaissent riba yakeba se finira non
mais
connaissent très bien ben tu vois il a
dit hey les mecs me dis-je une mais qui
êtes vous oui comme ça y est vous on ne
dérange de la piscine de l'es14 et on a
une minute pour trouver de qui il s'agit
ok non mais on ne pose aucune question
on doit dire non moi j'ai se posait donc
alors déjà il dit bonjour j'ai trouvé
bon on sait déjà c'est dans ses sauts
alors disons
vous voulez ça va trop loin du rythme
nourriture c'est ça rigolait [ __ ] aux
parties la répartie
les seules touches mais ça n'allait pas
merci je suis noir et après on va faire
un tour merci tout cas très beau
déguisement d'halloween
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais pas que
banderas tenez voilà grâce à ça mais je
reste on verra ce qu'appellent de leurs
voeux c'est à dire est une bande ou
wii s'aventurait sur église s il habite
à côté iglesias
ouattara dit succès dit l'un d'eux
cristiano ronaldo vous neymar n'est ma
baby marais de la brière ça va merci oui
il a dit boillon c'est bien de réception
il faut qu'il paye ses dettes
c'est pedro
[Applaudissements]
joe 2 minutes dans lequel
ses salades rejeter les collègues qui
martin ricky martin
ricky martin et ses packs tories qui
tartinent de là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça va oui rocco siffredi
alors que si freddy capelle matthieu
delormeau avec antonio banderas c'est
une femme
la personne matthieu delormeau la
personne est-elle française bah non non
mais non mais non on peut être fier mais
bonjour on est sur un niveau qui fait
que même je suis revenu dans l'émission
parce que je t'adore mais genre le gamme
propose du boulou s'emmerder pas que ça
pouvait partir non non non loca quoi
proposer du boulot non mais tu es au
téléphone
quand tu vas voir la suite alors si vous
dites nous qui s'y alors alors en effet
il s'agit et le gars me dit au téléphone
quand on a vu la citer que ces produits
en les roulant et a dit je t'ai vu à la
piscine tout ma poche
mais julie je ne suis pas manoir
mater il t'a dit conte d'amour il
fallait toujours un perdant et pourquoi
[Rires]
et
[Applaudissements]
sera gagnée si ça me touche parce que
apple ne te connais pas et rue de bercy
j'ai toujours
fait je te promets que ça ferai mes
toiles à l'entrée
des esses capelle jura c'est le petit
nom apple est il a il
il a chanté vous les femmes je crois que
c'était un dieu mois romain carette sur
téléfoot que
de loin avec ses 103 morts
il est bien allé dans mon oeuvre non il
est magnifique roulotté xi famille et
réchauffable au four
votre 250 millions d'albums vendus dans
les salons c'est bon c'est bon tu
t'inquiètes pas alors attendons donc la
tue à punta cana donc on le gaz à skis
c'est un fichier il avec les pages
blanches de la avec les pages jaunes
il a demandé à te parler à toi avec ça
bonjour
oui l'animateur la wii l'animateur sur
glace ouais j'habite mountakha n'a donc
à 45 mètres de voiture ouais nous aime
beaucoup jeu dans tpm et vous fait rire
non c'est non et je suis fan de loot est
vrai est-ce que vous venir passer
l'après-midi prendre le thé à neuf mois
et demi je vous dis que
les routiers matt et moi
tous les toits que l'on respecte
sim à respecter allez allez super
super dame et saint louis
l'anecdote est
politique je connais toutes ses chansons
par coeur mais c'est pas mais j'adore
aussi
les faits mais pas sa colère
au coeur et moi on n'a rien fait pour ça
mais voilà comme tous d'accord que même
en 2022 tu es toujours pas gay
alors que je te dire j'écoute mais je
n'écoute julio iglésias ouais je danse
sur mylène farmer et tu connais britney
spears parker pas du tout je suis
mélomane
j'aime bien ouais et je suis pas parti
avec un pote qui j'ai bouffé le qi mois
merci à l'état d'israël c'est tout un
bon
fils qu abbas
judy quand amy très bien après demain
non c'est fou deux jours après
c'est vrai coûte je respecte les
spectateurs elle devrait savoir que tu
es tu à punta cana il juste rien mais le
bouche à oreille joue l'attaquant matt
hagan sa quête n'est en vue pour hilaire
bonato imagine que
[Rires]
c'est beau c'est beaucoup dû alors est
donc tentant d'avaler quelques années
ouais tu prends la plus économe et le
problème de lui c'est qu'il connaît
comme les cancers de koné il connaît
tout le monde mais personne ne le
connaît ap voilà c'est pas faux oui
madame alors oui donc deux jours après
une voiture arrive il ya 45 minutes de
route pendant ces deux ans je regardais
puisqu'il a fait 250 mo d'albums vendus
tout ça et j'arrive devant sa maison
c'est à une maison tu m'auras plia c'est
un salaire takana réchauffer match aller
non on s'écroule lui exaspèrent écoule
barak il ya des mecs devant même avec la
vente devant avec des décalages de mecs
devant des kalachnikovs c'est sur ce
terreau local china north
patriots en armes mais les portes
s'ouvrent comme ça il est gardien
partout la maison est gigantesque et là
je vois arriver il et il marche un peu
mal comme sa démarche est un petit peu
mal à marcher à monsieur assez âgés
maintenant qui arrive c'est que je fous
de lui et qui me dit et je suis
tellement content de toujours c'est
presque mais j'arrive ya pas ses enfants
il veut juste lui et sa femme n'ont
miranda mironov vous dis donc miranda je
n'avais pas acquis par l appât
d'épicerie me reposer et je dis pourquoi
y aller
pour y attendre vainqueur mais comme ça
il explique que son père et son fils a
été enlevé non quand et où oui c'est
vrai
je n'ai pas inventé un sourire et elle
défend bien c'est un
salaire
minimum patrick église s est il il a une
idée devenue complètement parano est
devenu complètement parano et les gars
tout et il ya du coup il donc il a une
pièce écoute mode mais c'est vrai il ya
des piscines de partout ces gigantesques
yens pièce où il ya que des télés il est
câblé de partout dans une véritable sas
et les télés à l'aiep l'inversé c'est à
la résidence et
non sur tm explique qu'il veut venir en
autonomie donc il ya des animaux il ya
deux et deux petites éoliennes pour
l'électricité il dit que lui il veut au
cas où elle ne sort jamais il ya un
studio d'enregistrement en bas de chez
lui il fait ses disques depuis là qu'il
envoie il n'a pas bougé de la dengue
depuis deux ans une des noms ne bouge
pas il a un jet privé tous les goûts on
était confiné et attend bien le plus
beau je rentre dans une pièce et je vais
tout viser toutes les pièces avant qu on
peut noter écoute bien et là il ya plein
de petits cadres en argent il m'a bien
cet argent l'argent pas du plaqué par
les airs écoute bien l'anecdote dans
chaque petit cadre il ya lui qui posait
quelqu'un lui avec barack obama lui et
non pape et demi avec les locaux
[Rires]
écoutons de tuer va se retrouver à la
case et c'est bien avec madonna qu'elle
est venu à punta cana madonna il ya deux
ans elle a passé trois jours à la maison
ils l'adorent sa femme par les
partenaires va pas très bien français sa
femme était là heureusement je parle
espagnol et
egis assez avec le roi d'espagne ça avec
ma nana et il me dit est ce que tu veux
ton cadre non maintenant arrête je lui
dis mais pareil julliard est un
espace non
à l'état c'est toi qui parles bien moi
c'est moche français
tu
es
nouveau tu aussi une case silva me
canonica
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
foutu dehors
non mais non mais je raconte de sa mère
comme l'anecdote et bray et imagine des
juristes et d'autres lycéens en 2h02
entre nos questions étaient venus avec
ton n'avait pas fait la photo après je
vis avec mon ami zac ton ami et a dit
mme avait de quoi non comme ça n'est pas
pareil sans parler de nous mais il
délivre tout le temps tu voyais pas de
sujets de conversation c'est parce que
je te parle pas la porte je vous ai rien
demandé non mais côté
français
il parviendra bien alors messieurs
savais tu l'a pas dit que tu es fan de
lui tu vas pas dit alors lui il m'a dit
en revanche qui était fan de l'émission
alors il qu'au delà ce qu'est ce que
j'ai dit ce que didier pièce avec que
dtn là c'est sienna c'est l'été les
hongrois de la cmh il passe sa journée
devant la télé il marche très bien et on
l'adoré bientôt 80 ans j'ai pas demandé
tout ça c'est très surchargé en
décoration et des grandes joies de lui
quelques jours fous de lui et on a pris
la halle et on en a tellement vu
spectateurs parce que dans chaque pièce
on s'arrête et il est ça c'est ça ça
saigne garicoix qui a dit quoi bon on a
parlé de la télé on a parlé mais moi et
m'a demandé c'était gentil ah oui ouais
changé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il m'a demandé c'est pourquoi c'est
isabelle était vivant des gens
çà et là pour le coup dans l'appareil
l'émission qui regardent en replay il
m'a dit tu te rends pas toujours match
mais ça me fait beaucoup rire j'adore
cette émission comprend rien bah tu vas
voir tu m'accompagnes mais vous avez bu
un verre trouve à 2h30 pour visiter la
belle n'a évidemment qu'à prendre après
un été raté
je viens parce qu'il m'a dit qu'il pense
tout le temps du regret en ce cas de
danger parce qu'être dans
du vieux grec qua non du regret tout ça
donc on visité les animaux les marcheurs
étaient deux heures prendre plus de nos
coûts il s'est levé comme ça il m'a dit
ça mais j'étais très heureux c'est un
peu ça c'est très beau spa kobe d'un
s'étreignent à l'espagnol hé nian à la
main en cuir à ses
militants et la voiture m'a ramené au
club med mais je te jure c'est pas
du tout je sais qu'ils me regardent
maintenant
julio pour toi toi
message de
dépanner sur kiki vraiment